[Music]
no I'm Christiansen Avastin I had the
cloud and compute organization at Target
for those who shop at Target and who for
those who love shopping at Target I'm
sure you know that we are all about
inspiration and joy and for those who
don't know about Target we are one of
the biggest retailers in the u.s. across
50 states and I have a simple
proposition that I want to start with
any organization that wants to serve its
customers or is thinking about customer
satisfaction has to think about
inspiration and joy now how many of us
from an IT standpoint think inspiration
and joy at Target we do technology has
been a key factor behind target's growth
over the last few years and we are just
getting started
see it's even more critical because if
your goal is to be America's easiest
place to shop technology becomes a
foundational stone for us now having
said that we know that our guests have
high expectations they want us to do
well they believe in us they are rooting
for us they want us to innovate and
simply they just want us to be target so
with all these high expectations how do
we look up and out from a technology
standpoint how do we make sure that we
build the right platforms and
capabilities from an infrastructure
standpoint so that we are ready for a
future guest when they come up with
those new experiences over they are
looking for those new experiences and
that's what I'm going to talk about
today last year our CIO Mike McNamara
was at this very event and he shared the
business strategy and the technology
transformation our target as Mike stated
our strategy is indeed working and cloud
is an enabler and thank you to Google
for being part of the journey as well
in fact this is a fifth straight year
where we are growing 25 percent
year-over-year and I'm happy to say that
last year was the first year where we
ran hundred percent of our cloud
commerce workload on Google cloud
platform so Google thank you for a
flawless holiday season in 2018 together
we came together and we provided our
guests some phenomenal experiences now
what you see in the screen is these are
industry-leading fulfillment services
for a guest and we're just adding on
more and more to it a couple of examples
let's say you are at work and you want
to make that order you're looking for
something but you don't have the
patience to wait for two days
you have the capability now to make that
order online from your work and pick it
up on your way back home what about this
a busy mom it's raining she has two
little ones little ones in her backseat
and one of them is starting to throw
some tantrums the other ones beginnings
starts to begin to meltdown and I know
some of us have been there she does not
have to get out of a car and what we
have done is we have given that mom the
capability to punch in that order and
when she drives her car to the parking
lot our team members get notified
through a geolocation service and within
two minutes our store team members will
come and place the order in the car
truck and these are the experiences that
we are talking about in the future now
how did we get here I would say there
are three foundational principles our
target we believe in first technology
has to be experience focused now what do
I mean by that a target experiences
takes first before technology does all
of us have been an incident out ages and
operational calls something happens we
get on a call and this is where typical
IT organization do there's a server
failure there's a database failure or
some software developer over there did a
full table scan broad
brought down an application at Target we
look at it a little bit different when
we have an outage or an incident at
Target yes all of us do get on the call
but the first question we ask is what is
the impact with the guest what is the
impact to the team member we understand
that very clearly and then we talk about
what is the technical or technology
issues second architecture must be
simple elegant and adaptive and what I
mean by that is when we write
applications at target we want to make
sure that we don't have a vendor lock-in
and there is this foundational principle
that platforms are the path to the
future and not just tools and the third
thing I would say is technology has to
embrace cloud and open source which is
why we went with Google now we all know
that cloud gives us a speed and agility
and elasticity and all that good stuff
but what about open source a target when
we have a solution and we're looking for
a solution for a problem the first thing
we do is internally look inside and see
whether we can repurpose a solution that
we already have if for some reason
that's not available we then go to the
open source community and we look at it
and if for some reason that's not
available we then go ahead and write it
on our own we wouldn't even before we go
to the vendors and the best part is once
we write it we contribute back to the
open source community so I talked about
these high expectations earlier that
guess having us they want us to do well
they want us to be target they want us
to innovate this is where the next
chapter of innovation comes in that I
talked about earlier which is all about
focusing on our guests and our team
members in the future bead a quart of
milk or the beautiful drug you're
looking at or that perfect gift that you
want for somebody target is a positive
force behind millions of people in the
US every single day now we have about 30
million of our guests shop at our stores
every month about 100 million visits in
our digital fronts so to do this we
operate in at about 1,850 stores we have
29 or 39 distribution centers we have
our own two
data centers and yes we also have Google
cloud as well but and here's a challenge
that comes in what if what if all these
assets came together seamlessly what if
I could take a workload and just deploy
it across the board and what if I don't
look at these eighteen hundred and fifty
stores as stores but I look at them as
yet another extension of my cloud so
tomorrow I'm not going to have just GCP
I may have 1,850 cloud environments just
think about that power and the
capability and the scalability that we
can get and what if there is a scenario
where I have five stores in New York
three stores in San Francisco I want to
do two pilots the same day I get the
results back and I pick one of them
because one has a better experience for
a guest and within a few hours what if I
can just deploy to 1,850 stores across
the hundreds of thousands of devices
that are running on those stores we have
close to 130,000 Android mobile devices
that are running in those stores and
what if I can do that seamlessly and
here's the best part what if I could do
everything that I said and still make
the underlying infrastructure completely
invisible to our engineers so they are
focused on what they're good at which is
to write great software that can delight
our guests and make our team members
happy they don't have to worry about
underlying technology they don't have to
worry about patches the version upgrades
we take care of all of that and that's
what we have been working on a target
our engineers have been hard at work for
the last 18 months building this
platform a target to solve this exact
challenge for the future within target
we call it as tap or ta P which stands
for a target application platform the
mission of this platform is very simple
its to make target the best place to
write and deliver software with zero
touch infrastructure so in closing I
want to go back to my initial
proposition that I made that any
organization that wants to
provide great customer service must
focus on inspiration and joy our guests
get inspiration and joy from our
products and services which they love
and they're rooting for us our store
meme store team members get inspiration
and joy by delivering those services to
our guests our technology team members
get inspiration and joy by building and
innovating for the next set of
experiences and that's the thing about
inspiration and joy when it's going
great
you get to renew it every single day and
that's what we do at Target and we're
just getting started
thank you and have a wonderful
conference
[Music]